I got a lot of really great emails I've
got a lot of great messages through
social media letters written letters get
all those kinds of things and I
appreciate them all III don't always
respond to all of them because there's I
physically cannot do it yeah and of
course you know Oh get someone to manage
your social media or whatever I'm not
doing that um if you hear back from me
you hear from me not from somebody that
I paid $10 an hour to respond to my
stuff and say cool get after it like no
I'm not doing that but you know I get
all these things and I do read them so
if you send it I read it and so I
appreciate the feedback and everything I
got one though that that was good I
wanted to actually wanted to read on
here because I felt that it not only
said hey thanks for you know the podcast
or whatever thanks for the books
whatever it actually gave some pretty
good methodology and really an inset
into a mindset that I think will help
people doing what they're doing so here
we go mr. willing just wanted to share a
quick story with you at 39 I had fallen
into a 15-year rut of undisciplined
alcoholism I was soft and heavy and
wanted to change earlier this year I had
started working out three to four times
a week in my basement I was trying and
failing to get a handle on my alcohol
abuse every failure made the Beast seem
bigger and unbeatable it was like I
didn't have control over my body I
finished your book on a Monday night and
decided that I would get up early the
next morning and work out I got up and
worked out not much but I just wanted to
do something sit-ups push-ups 15 minutes
on the bike worked out twice Tuesday got
up Wednesday and did it again got the
Thursday night a normal drinking night
and decided to try not drinking made it
through
Friday same thing worked out morning and
night stayed busy and stayed away from
the drink thought I should try and push
it through the weekend worked out
Saturday morning took the rest of the
weekend off and stayed dry Monday
morning I got up and started to a daze
again made it through the week with 11
workouts by the second week I felt
better than I had in my entire life
I was astounded that normal people
walked around feeling this good I guess
not systematically poisoning your body
will do that on the fifth week I got a
project at work that was gonna require
traveling for the next eight weeks I was
worried about overcoming my triggers and
Road habits a normal traveling evening
was dinner watch cable and drink eight
beers to my surprise the hotel at a
sweet gym cool I'll just keep doing what
I'm doing then at the site I found out
that we would start work at 6 a.m.
damn that means I have to get up at 4:00
to work out I'm 12 weeks into my
traveling two a days usually getting
eleven to twelve workouts a week they
recently moved our start time to 7:00
a.m. so now I get an hour and a half in
the morning and evening I'm 16 weeks
clean drop thirty pounds or more haven't
been on a scale in three weeks 34 waist
jeans hang off of me bus it up and
pushed up sets went from ten to forty to
fifty kettlebell swings went from 35 by
10 to 50 by 15 I started to learn how to
run as I haven't done it in 20 years now
after a day off I can do two miles
without stopping I do 4 to 5 miles on
the treadmill and 9 miles on the bike
besides the sit-ups push-ups kettlebells
core and weights
I look forward to next year's
competitive shooting season I'm going to
bring it at this point my cravings are
gone and I actually recoil from the
smell of booze when I started this I
thought it would be temporary now it's
going to be permanent no reason to waste
time with it anymore now when I question
something your voice comes to me with
the hard answer it's only black and
white with no gray area one day when I'm
standing before the Lord Lord and hear
his voice if it doesn't sound like yours
I might be disappointed the book I read
those months ago was the way of the
warrior kid I'm working on extreme
ownership now thank you for your service
thank you for producing a badass podcast
and thank you for influencing my life so
there you go and I say this to people
all the time most important here is it
isn't me yet to you and sure you may
have grabbed some little foothold from
the podcast or from one of the books but
it isn't me that changes you it's you
you set the small goals you achieve
those goals then set some more and
achieve those and set some more goals
maybe a little bit bigger but not that
much bigger you pay attention to the
progress this guy is 16 weeks deep
thirty pounds lighter working harder
stronger faster more efficient
competitive the individual that wrote
that is getting after it and changing
his life and you can too
just start start small start with
changing tomorrow morning just tomorrow
morning get that squared away
and then move on to the next day and the
next and move your life to a better
place one little step one little victory
at a time